so location we talked about that what
about income
so
actually i got a bunch of uh guys that
drop questions
on the community tab of my channel so
i'm going to throw those up in the
screen in a bit but one of the things i
really wanted to talk about was
income
there's a lot of guys right now
that have messaged me
um
talking about how their jobs are
threatened and
they feel like
they either have to take the jab or
they're not going to have work
okay
in some cases they're not even firing
people
they're just saying if you don't do what
we tell you to do we're not going to
give you work right so if you're like
working for an organization where they
get sent out on jobs
if you haven't ticked off their boxes
they're not going to give you the job so
they're not going to fire you they're
just not going to give you work to do so
it's effectively the same thing a lot of
these guys some of them you know work
for police forces fire services uh
medical services
uh you know the frontline guys that we
were all praising oh we praise our
frontline workers you know all of that
you know
circus that we did a couple years ago
when the beer bug kicked off now all of
a sudden these guys are nobodies it's
take the job or lose your job and it's
it's hilarious to me because i mean the
narrative that you hear all the time is
oh the oh the icus are overwhelmed and
you know we have to take the jab to you
know save the icu's from being
overwhelmed it's like you know and then
the next breath and they want to fire
like
25 of their staff
just doesn't make any sense it doesn't
add up i mean are you guys clueing in
here yet or is it just me
income is real important so how do you
protect your ability
to earn
in
whatever currency it is that you decide
to earn it you know you can earn in fiat
you can earn in crypto you can become
self-employed there's barter systems out
there of course
um you know i was watching this um in
depth
um
how can i put this you know if you're
you know familiar with the amish or the
mennonites you see them around you know
in rural country with their you know
horse and buggies and the funny thing is
is they're probably the best position
automatically believe it or not to enjoy
this decline
they don't have access to any
outside information for the most part
depending on how conservative or liberal
their structure is but for the most part
they don't drive they don't have cell
phones they don't have radios or tv none
of this stuff impacts them they don't
deal with a wokeness they don't deal
with any political influence all they
really do is pay some taxes they don't
even bother voting
because to them you know the highest
order for them is their own religion
so um you know it's funny because when i
was watching i was thinking damn man
these guys got it set up so that not a
lot in the outside world can potentially
bother them that much unless they show
up and they start cramming stuff down
their throat and they're gonna have to
deal with that uh problem as well
so you know your income
you know you gotta have the ability to
barter you know because all that because
all that money is is just a
um it's just a storage of value it's
just a store of value really you know
it's all that it boils down to because
you go back you know 10 20 000 years ago
there was i mean
as as a cooper my last name basically
meant barrel maker okay so anybody in
the uk that had the last name made
barrels
and then you know you'd of course have
smiths you know you'd have blacksmiths
and stuff like that and stuff and
there'd be people that would farm
chickens and cows and hay and freaking
you know bear make barrels and stuff
like that and then they would barter you
know whatever but the problem was was
that in those days like a barrel is good
for a long time you can make a barrel
sit there it's good but your harvest of
perishables isn't so the question you
know then came up well how do you store
value in something that has been created
and they started using things like gold
and silver and precious metals and stuff
like that we switched over to paper
money and
you know we're starting to move over to
uh kryptos right the pivot is happening
so
that's all that money is is a store of
value so you need to be able to have
access to value to exchange it for stuff
right real estate transportation
housing you know shelter food whatever
that may be so
a lot of guys you know like i said
earlier they're they're about ready to
lose their freaking jobs right i mean
there's guys here in the chat right now
i know one of them
that you know has been threatened take
the job or you're losing your job right
so how do you preserve that you know do
you want to keep working for woke
corporations because
it's it's hey listen
i'm probably older than a lot of the
audience that watches my stuff there's
some guys that are even older than me
you don't realize that but
for the most part
when i was 20 none of this stuff existed
there was no
quotas agendas wokeness none of this
stuff it was just
hey you come to work you do your job
you get paid we'll do the christmas
party we'll do the summer barbecue we'll
have the watermelon eaton contest and
all that sort of stuff and everybody
gets paid in there you know they go on
happy go lucky but we're actually in a
position now if you want to enjoy the
decline you got to figure out a way to
preserve your income
right because if you're going to rely on
some dude
that's woke as well
that's feeding the you know
the the fed narrative you know the state
narrative cramming it down your throne
you don't want to do something they say
oh if you don't do this you know if you
don't wear this
pink [ __ ] hat or something like that
we're going to fire you
what are you going to do you're going to
keep bending over taking it all the time
you got to figure out a way to make sure
that your income's good you know you got
to enjoy that decline best way in my
view to do that is entrepreneurship
that's been my chosen path i mean i left
the corporate world
17 18 years ago
i have not
i'm
i'm working on getting this thing called
the tn visa for for travel
and uh one of the things they asked me
was for my pat not for my passport but
for my cv for my resume
i just laughed i'm like i have not been
employed for a long time i do not have a
resume or a cv
right so you know we had to hop on a
call and talk about that with
one of the partners there
but uh yeah you gotta you gotta make
sure your income sorted out guys you
wanna enjoy that decline you gotta make
sure you have a steady source of income
and
the most
powerful thing that you can do is not
rely on somebody else
there's a lot of guys right now like i
said about 25 of the work workforce
approximately somewhere between 20 and
25 percent of the workforce right now is
afraid to lose their job in many places
in the west canada especially i know
it's starting to happen in the u.s and
they're really pissed off about it
and and they're left with this decision
do i do i breach my values
and yield
or what like what's the next option so
how do you enjoy
that decline in that environment
right i mean maybe fight like one of the
things i would be asking potential
employers right now is what their
position is on certain things
right especially if they're trying to
poach you from another company like if
they're trying to steal you from another
company and they're trying to lure you
lure you into their business find out
what kind of business that's being run
right who runs the show what's it all
about what's their value system is it
something that's going to allow me to
enjoy my decline right
good questions to ask
right you know it's the same sort of
thing like i put out on twitter
in the last week i said something like
i'm not going to get into any business
dealings or partnerships with anybody on
a go forward basis that's vaccinated
themselves because they're too gullible
for me to trust
that's what it boils down to for me so
ask yourself questions like that right
you got to take a look at that i know i
know there's a lot of people watching
this right now that probably have been
vaccinated they're like
i just did it i didn't want to do it but
i just did i've talked to a lot of guys
just you know i don't want to get fired
i got a family to feed
i don't know man how do you enjoy how do
you enjoy yourself in that environment
the question you gotta ask right
what are you going to use to store value
cryptocurrency is great for that i know
some guys don't like it
well it's gonna go to zero it's gonna go
to zero rich yeah we've been saying that
for how many years now 11 years
keeps going up
you know you compare it side to side to
any other
store of value or
you know market and it just destroys it
so i don't know
what like three three percent of the
world population
uses crypto i don't know what the
percentage is that has gold or silver i
mean i got gold and silver too but
cryptocurrency to me seems like it's
it's going to be the obvious winner
what are you going to store value in you
know you got to figure that out too
right
make sure you got that thing and and i
wouldn't put it all in one place like i
see people pile it all into real estate
i see people pile i see people piled it
all into one token on the blockchain
there's there's idiots out there that
brag like there's this one guy uh i
think they call him the dogecoin
millionaire and he looks exactly how you
think he would look
and you know he's going on about
how he piled all of his money into
deutsche coin and made
a couple million dollars off it or it's
worth a couple million dollars he hasn't
made yet because i believe he's holding
he's not selling it but again
don't put it all in one place you got to
diversify that [ __ ] spread it out right
put it into things you know that that
can be moved that that are good stores
of value that are that are that are
gonna hold or appreciate and value in
the future like there's like there's
gonna be a demand for it okay
so pay attention though you wanna enjoy
the decline
make sure you have stores of value and
currency that's useful
you